big mouth I'm a big fan of big mouth all
all credit there goes to Nick Kroll and
Andrew Goldberg and marked and Jenn
Flacco who created it I'm very lucky to
do a voice well but your voice was very
good and I was talking to Nick Kroll
about it and Nick Kroll on this show
sitting in that very seat said that he
there's no good way to say this but he
was complimenting you on because your
character has to simulate vocally many
orgasms and Nick was going on and on
about the variety and intensity of your
simulated orgasms he was going on and on
about it
a lot of times when we're recording the
show they'll say like can you give us
just a half orgasm you know I just go
just like the hint of one and I was like
don't you have these from old episodes
can you reuse them but yes now you know
what Nick said to me now I know what it
sounds like when you orgasm and again as
with the crashing I'm acting and how
dare you
oh how dare you yes of course that's how
I sound when I orgasm yes of course I'm
an [ __ ] but how dare you well this is
speaking of not being a good actor this
I found this recently in a yearbook and
I just wanted to show it because
apparently at one point yes this was in
third grade at the end of the year we
all got these everyone's nuts about
cards what the Acorn drawing yeah
everyone's nuts about John Waite the
acorns eating an acorn oh my god that's
horrible
it's eating its own that's not kosher no
what a chilling message to send to the
kids
maybe it's kissing its son looks like
it's eating it yeah that is so weird but
we're getting off-track he is a great
actor an impersonator that's good for
you I guess I was in 1991 but that's the
last time anyone has said you're a great
actor in a person they saw something
they were right there was something said
you'll be in the arts
you're an eccentric cuz I had a
briefcase and was listening to crooners
all day long but I can do a lot of
impressions I can do any athlete in any
entertain or any politician but we're
never gonna see no proof of it but we
don't have time to do them but I can do
it